my channel is sponsored by casetify
which means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
because i thought that it would be
really fun
i decided that i was going to go through
and watch a bunch of trailer reactions
to see
the internet reacting to the god of war
ragnarok trailer if you haven't seen my
reaction it is up on my youtube channel
i cried a whole lot
for context obviously this is my video
right here
um i work at sony santa monica studio my
biggest concern with streaming this is
that they'll be like just stuff that
i'll want to say but i will just have to
be silent like if they're wrong about
something or write about something i
will just have to not say anything it's
gonna it's gonna be a little bit tough
but i'm really excited to see people get
excited
he's got a santa monica studio cup
and the shot and the
game trace oh my god
bro
what's up did you see the new ragnarok
trailer
this is so pretty so cool
what
why are you looking at me like that
oh my
yeah
don't say it
no
no
oh my god
the production value
i really should turn the ads off
okay
i assume they're kind of fun
what's up everybody
we're here to check out board trailer
[Music]
initially so they did not think we would
return boy yeah he's doing a really good
job of chris
i don't know if he always would be able
to stay in character for this so it's
been like two years since we played
three
three years
this jacket is so tight on me bro
bro like around the arms i feel like i'm
about to bust out of it but anyway
we are here to watch trailer for god of
war right now yeah super super excited
um they're waiting on this game this is
amazing the first one i thought the
flawless first playstation game that
i've ever platinum santa monica actually
invited us out to the studio hey santa
monica yes forever grateful to them for
that that was dude thank you
any time
the last game cause i'm pretty sure
they're gonna top it and this is gonna
be another classic so
with that being said we're gonna jump
right in begin the journey
bro
it's you
it's a big butcher the audio quality
son
is that a tree yes
he's huge
the boy is a man
how many years no
he's a teenager time is running out
the prophecies say femme winter leads to
ragnarok
war is coming bruh
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki yeah loki
i want people to flip out about the sled
so bad because i know
how hot it was
to make and do those answers lead to war
with asgard
bro maybe that's what mother won
we do not know what mother watching
war with asgard disappeared
i'd recognize that java expression
anywhere
bro yo we get the right
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's people
if he's out there those people you gotta
find him
son
is this the doorbell
i think this is the door
like the dwarves yeah what if the only
way to do that
bro
stop
[Music]
it's not the only way
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general
this is so good i love this
that's so into it i guess i'm covering
him
bro was that
the [ __ ] son i'm tripping right now
look at these [ __ ] combos
no it's a crisis
this is so cool
[Music]
including overloading bro do you see
what he saw
he's huge
bro
that's tyr the god of war for [ __ ] um
for the norse they said he was dead
that's what they were looking for yeah
that's real god of war fans i've seen
some people be like are they trying to
say thor
or are they saying here
is alive
but that's what they were talking about
they were saying that they had to go
find him but but in the first game like
he was dead like that was the whole
thing they were like oh he's dead
bro wow
wow that looks so crazy wow
so i almost i literally almost cheered
up bro that's so good
save the same bro it's just more of the
same but better i'm i'm with it it is
time to talk about tastify if you didn't
already know case device is a company
that makes extremely cool
uh cases and covers for iphones and
smartphones in general it's all neatly
wrapped and they sent me a little
a cute little letter so this does
mention one very cool thing the impact
cases specifically are approved by a
drop test for 6.6 feet of ultra impact
cases which are over nine feet which i
think we should test i'm a little bit
scared but let's do it so we've got my
phone here
i'm gonna put it inside of my case defy
case here you can see the bump is super
clearly on this one
okay
it is in fact
exactly the same completely fine they
also on top of that are made with 50
fully recyclable materials and are
shipped to you in 100 compostable
packaging they also have which is a
thing that i love antimicrobial coating
this eliminates 99 of bacteria that can
get on your phone by preventing the
growth of microbes which ew you don't
want i think these would be a really
cool gift especially because you can
customize them and there is a new iphone
coming out pretty soon so why don't you
get a case defy case if you get a new
phone go to www.castify.com
alana today to get 15 off your new
favorite phone case that is casedify.com
alana bro
what did he summon and also when someone
said
bro
what is it called the in freaking ah and
thor the the frost the frost the [ __ ]
gate that heimdale
guards the way how thor gets um [ __ ]
the the bifrost yes yeah they did you
see oh that's what the that's how the
enemies showed up
oh that's
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the combat looks [ __ ] nice savage i
hope that they kept the one camera
system and it looks like they did yeah
like the way the camera was going i was
actually kind of peeping that so cause
they can't really go backwards from that
like this they set that standard and you
gotta keep that going forward yo i'm so
high
uh this man you have no idea how hard it
was to keep ourselves from watching this
trailer yeah
all of this oh
that's a lot of effort i love that
i really like these guys they're super
cool
hold up hold up hold up okay bro they
just keep hitting us with these bangers
that sound that sounded like craven
talking towards oh my god
i'm in front of him
gameplay
he's grown up he's gamepl up
guys playstation just keeps on hitting
us running out okay this enthusiasm is
incredible
war is coming
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there look at his face
who i am oh my god
he's a teenager
friend don't fight anymore everyone just
yells
and if those answers lead to war with
asgard oh my god
maybe that's what mother wants this this
must have what mother what
oh my god come on here well
i recognize that y'all gotta express
that everyone does that too they go
friends
oh
[Applause]
an excellent
[Music]
bro
this is incredible
i've never seen this much excitement
before in my life
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
is he okay
here
god of war what is it called ragnarok so
it is called ragnarok okay you'll get
your answer soon enough
i can't like my my heart is still coming
something smarty main truth show us
about spider-man
[Laughter]
oh
release date okay okay they're giving us
they're giving us a breather like i need
this i love watching the people who know
all their names
that's what gets me is all the people
who are like brock sendri freya mamia
like the people who just like know
exactly
who they're
looking at
hey okay
this is their their their big finisher
[Music]
it's not abandoned
sorry to say
good boy
so good to see you
maybe that's what mother won
the girl on the right breathe
please do breathe she looks so intense
i recognize that
well i'm dead man who didn't seem pretty
keynote i love the hug in the first game
you'll get your answer soon enough
that's exciting
well some of them
i don't know who you are
give me a date give me a date she said i
get answers soon enough though give me a
date mary jane
give me a date that looks cool
[Laughter]
this is new i haven't seen this before
no shot at the remaster
[Laughter]
oh god it's
time is running out
boy's a teenager bro let's go
everybody's very stoked about boy being
a teenager bro i don't want to [ __ ]
history
i just want answers oh my god those
fancies oh my god
oh my god
he means here
the old god of war in these lands
who's dead
dead man who didn't seem pretty keen on
seeing he wasn't found
if he's out there
we gotta find him oh my god
oh i love it we're trying to stop
ragnarok to help people humans and what
if the only way to do that isn't that
darling then he just saw
okay that's it it's not the only way
[Music]
people this is so good this is so good
this is so good appreciate that thank
you yeah
thank you thank you thank you
don't worry about it
can you can you stop asking
for the
and why is this happening
okay who is this this is com
bo nano she has 5.3 subs so let's do it
please got a war
[Music]
finally
is that our boy
boy
be out there who i am
i didn't expect everyone to be so
surprised by his age
i just want answers
maybe that's your mother she's gonna
hunt our ass
yes
oh it's so good
[Music]
oh my goodness people really like that
huh
yes
yes
oh my god i'm coming with us
oh he's a big boy
please you'll get your answer soon
enough
well some of them it's so funny that she
said when is it coming out please and
then
anger goes you'll get your answer soon
enough
that's amazing like the guy earlier he
was like is that where the dwarfs are
from which is svardalheim
to watch somebody like
have thought about that you know and
like it's it exists in their world too
i don't even need shut up everybody shut
up
oh my god dude oh my god here we go god
oh god it's gonna drink something oh man
the lake of nine is frozen over
[Music]
stop thinking like a father for a moment
i respect how intense they are it's so
cool he's like i just got back to being
a good guy you're trying to get me back
again
wait
are you a calm and
[Music]